hello everyone how are you guys doing
hope life is great wherever you are this
is spanish grandmaster pepe
and it's a great pleasure to be here
with all of you welcome to this insane
in the end game lecture where we're
gonna solve some
interesting puzzles artistic puzzles
from the platof brothers so i think you
guys can see
the board properly and everything right
so
we are ready to go so can you tell me
what artistic puzzles are
well probably you can yeah so puzzles
that didn't happen in
games but actually were composed by
famous composers
and they actually can help you to
improve
your creativity your logic and can help
you in
many different ways so hello to
everybody out there in the chat
as you guys know i like to do these
lectures very
interactive so please if you have any
suggestions
any questions i'm here just for you
so good evening from london england hi
george what's up
so i'll be asking you some questions and
we will be focusing on
very difficult puzzles i'm very
beautiful
so the plateau of brothers who are they
well they were from latvia
and uh we were basically solving puzzles
from 100 years ago
but the quality of them are very amazing
all right guys so let's start with the
first one
this is a very beautiful puzzle it's
white
to move in this position we can see that
we are an exchange down
right but we have two dangerous past
pawns
in this position the f pawn and
the e pawn so yeah if we start thinking
then we realize that it for example we
play e6
then black goes rook e4 and then no
matter where we go for example king d3
we just take this pawn on e6 we attack
the facundo pawn
f6 and after f7 we just chase this pawn
and then we end up
winning the game so s e6 sorry
doesn't work so what should we play here
in this position
you want to go f7 you want to go e takes
d6 e takes d6 looks horrible
you want to go king e3 maybe well
you play king e3 trying to stop this
rook
coming to f4 well black can just take on
e5 and then
after f7 this pawn is actually covering
the f4 square
so that's why rook f4 just wins the game
so king e3 is not working either so
e6 not working kidney 3 not working
what happens if we play f7 well
f7 we can't we had to go rook f4 in this
position otherwise
that's gonna be a queen and after e6
intend to go e7 black goes king d8 then
again
black has managed to stop those phones
so what should we do here with the white
pieces then you guys have any idea
in this position
i'm sure you do come on george
give me some moves yeah so basically we
said e6 not working f7 not working
king e3 not working so what's the best
move for white here in this position
right it's knight c3
knight c3 and now black has two main
options
so yeah move the knight that's right
so black now has two options so the
first one is
rook f4 and the next one is rook a5 and
both of them give us a lot of troubles
i mean after some move like rook a8 we
just go e6 and then two these two pass
pawns
decide again so let's say that black
goes
with rook f4 so now how do we continue i
mean
black is just taking on e5 and then
taking on f6 if we go e6
black just captures that pawn on f6 so
basically we don't have too many options
in this position
if white goes king e3 then d take c5
sorry protecting the rook and then f6
false
so we are basically forced here to go
knight d5
and now what happens that's right
george what happens if i go rook e4
my idea is just to take this pawn on e5
and then try to stop the f1
but there's actually a winning move in
this position it's very beautiful
so where do you go with the king to f3
to d3 to d1 to f1
f2 d2 you have six options of course you
wanna
play knight e3 in this position right hi
pepe lots of love from india
hey what's up there
so
i speak some hindi yeah absolutely
so where do you go with the king well if
you go to f3
this is actually a terrible move because
after rook e5
now you want to go f7 but then
rook f5 and then just grabs the pawn so
instead you're gonna go to d3 in this
case
because if black takes now on e5 there's
a winning move
for white in this position which is
exactly f7 george that's right because
there is a fantastic
four on e7 just taking the rook if you
go rook f5 and then
you take the knight of course we go kini
4 then we cover f5
and after rook e5 we just go kin f4 and
there is no way to stop this point
beautiful right so the other variation
that arises from after rook a5 is even
more beautiful let's see if you guys
managed to win the game after rook a5
so now basically same idea i mean
white is going e6 so rookie 5 rook takes
e6 so e6 is just losing
so i'm gonna give you a hint
okay white goes f7 and now after rookie
five
then you gotta tell me what to move in
this position
as you can see now white i mean black is
the same into gold r5 in the next move
so how do we stop this
it's a very beautiful move i mean this
plateau of artistic end games are just
amazing yeah
so what do you play here with the white
pieces come on george
i know you can solve this again
so you guys have any idea
in this position knight e4
that's right very good all ankle
leonardo
igor laniela knight e4
fantastic move if black goes rook f5
then there is a fork and then knight
takes f5
and if rook takes e4 of course we don't
go to d3
but instead we go to f3 and then there's
no way
to stop this f8 square by the way guys
the background today is different
because
i flew to madrid today because we have
an
event tomorrow with the real madrid
football club actually we are combining
chess with football
and this this house is actually full of
grand masters now
so there is anton numbers to spain ivan
salvado
also member from the olympic team so
after this session we're going to play
some blitz games
till 3 a.m or 4 a.m i know myself
all right so very beautiful puzzle from
from pieto from platof let's go to the
second one
right the second one that i have
prepared for you guys so
it's white to move in this position
we're a pizza but then this pawn is
almost
promoting right so white is going in
this direction
and black is going in this direction
right
so what do you put what do we play here
with the white pieces
well the first move that can come to
your mind is bishop v8
and then trying to run with this one so
h2
f7 h1 f8
but then after some checks finally this
pawn on d5 is gonna fall
and then queen and bishop against win
it's a draw
so we cannot go for this simple idea
we have to find different resource in
this position because we have to stop
this pawn on
the h file which basically is is
promoting in two moves so how do we do
this
nice line right your yeah these puzzles
i'm sure you're gonna enjoy them
and if you're teaching some kids for
example you can show them
this kind of lines d6 okay that has to
be the idea
or the white is losing so
you're gonna find like i mean this is
the only move basically if white is
winning so basically we have that hint
and we know that white has to win and if
bishop v8 is not working
then g6 has to be the idea now black has
two possibilities
and we have to react differently
depending how black captures in d6 let's
start with the move
c takes e6 so now
what do we play here with the white
pieces it's a beautiful
idea leonardo you are so strong today
what did you eat
what did you eat today leonardo
that's right bishop d5
fantastic move of course now you wanna
stop this this bomb but then somebody at
home can be saying come on stupid
spanish guy what are you
talking like are you serious
pepe peppon are you serious people
well now after king takes d5
this is gonna remind you to some movie
is is this position like bringing you
memories about some movie that you
already watched
maybe some years ago
i don't know how the movie is called in
english but the direct translation
from spanish to english would be like
searching for bobby's
for bobby fischer something like that so
now f7
h2 f8
h1 and now queen a8
that's right searching searching for
bobby fischer
amazing movie right i remember like
i watched it like 20 years ago or
something like that i enjoy it
so much and then you captured the queen
that's right
but okay after d6 black has another
option
black can take with the king as well so
now what do we play
in this position beautiful right bishop
d5
so now what's the idea
you want to go bishop d5 in this
position again
maybe sounds like a
possibility right in this position would
you go bishop b5
bishop d5s are in this position or not
now there's a slight difference in the
position
because if you go bishop d5 right now
then black can just take the bishop and
now f7 h2
f8 h1 and now actually queen a
is not working because black has c6 and
actually black is a little bit better in
this position
so that's why we cannot go bishop d5 at
this moment
but then there is another move yeah
bishop
c4 bishop c4 not working
h2 f7 h1
f8 and now the kin let's say can go to
d7 for example
so what's the idea now after c take
sorry after king takes e6
the idea is bishop e8 fantastic move
again
because now after h2 f7 h1
f8 now that you can see that the kin is
forced to go well we have to force this
game to go
to the light squares because if the king
arrives to d5 then we have the same idea
with bishop c6 for example king d5
bishop c6 king takes and then queen 88
and then we
again win the queen win the queen right
but after f8
black can still try to survive with the
move key in e5 and then there is a
fantastic
killer shot in this position for white
can you find it
can you give me the best move for white
here in this position
so as you can see these artistic puzzles
i mean
make you think differently right because
i mean these ideas are
very strange in a normal chess game
right
so it helps you like improving your
creativity that's for sure
and that can help you in your chess game
tournaments right
queen f6 that's right again we force
this kin
these squares are covered so this king
has to go to the light squares and then
bishop c6 just comes
and wins the game beautiful guys sweet
you guys managed to do it again awesome
let's go let's move to the third one
this is a bit easier
this is a bit easier i'm gonna tell you
guys so white is going in this direction
and black is going in this direction
okay
so if i mean you have heard me talking
about forcing moves
like all the time right i mean i'm
all the time saying you should get you
should consider forcing moves like
captures checks and threads so
not immediately but in this puzzle you
will have to
use this to solve it but i mean what
we i mean what do you play here with the
white pieces the first move is actually
pretty natural right
i mean our only idea to to win this game
is to push the pawn right and then black
will try
to stop that pawn so e5 is actually
the best move and the winning move
let's see how because now black has to
try to
stop this pawn and black cannot do it by
playing c5 because we just grabbed this
beautiful monster on a8 and then we just
win the game
so that's why black's only move to
survive here is bishop
b7 so now we just push
with e6 and now black goes bishop c8
we push and then bishop d7
and again we reach another critical
moment so
what is your best moving in this
position for y
come on this is time to think right
we're gonna see some deflection themes
moves like that
maybe you want to bring the kin to f7 to
f6 maybe you wanna
move the bishop so what do you play here
guys
bishop a3 that's right that's the best
move in the position because if you go
bishop
f7 which could look like a winning move
because we're you're actually
threatening bishop a3 black has the same
move which is c5
and now after bishop h3 this bishop
can't count to this diana can't stop the
pawn
so that's why after bishop d7 we're
gonna go bishop a3
black's only move is bishop e8 now
probably you find the next move
kin f8 but still it's not the end
because black can actually play bishop
h5 so now
what do you play with the white pieces
again deflection all the time the
flexion this bishop is controlling e8
we want to promote so let's try to
deviate this bishop from that square so
next move is
come on guys give me the next two moves
you're doing fine today you are so
focused
i like it by the way guys tomorrow
you know hernan solari solari
argentinian chess football player he's
gonna play
a chess game against magnus carlsen and
i have to do commentary on that and this
is gonna be
in real madrid stadium i mean magnus is
gonna be
online but uh you know i'm a little bit
nervous you know so it's gonna be
an amazing experience for sure yeah
bishop g4
and then this forces black to go bishop
g6 and then we just play bishop f5 check
if this king was on uh on c3 then
probably this would be a draw because
black could try to play bishop h5 but in
this case
this is a check black is first to take
and then we promote
with e8 oh fine all right awesome
let's move to the fourth one i prepared
for you guys
eight puzzles for today
so let's go let's get it ready to ramble
next puzzle white move
we got this past pawn on the h5
so
well what's your first idea what's
the first move that comes to your mind
in this in this position
probably age six right probably h6
is the move that comes to your mind and
then you realize that at akin g5 check
then this this pawn is falling and
basically black's fine so
basically black makes a draw
so bishop c7 somebody is
proposing well i just grabbed the fruit
you know you give me free fruit you know
i love
kiwis and i'll just take that kiwi on c7
and then if you go h6 this bishop is
doing the same job in this diagonal so
king g5 and there just
take this one on h6 so
these puzzles are extremely easy master
okay milan tell me the solution then
not so not so easy actually
this is even great for for for
international master for a grand master
to train i mean
i took some time to solve them i had to
be honest with you it was not immediate
for me
so come on tell me tell me melania the
solution now that you know the solution
you say this is too easy
for you so then give me the solution
yeah
bishop d2 well bishop d2
i guess black can just play keen f5
and then after 86 which is your idea
basically this position
well this is actually a check so you got
to move and then i take on c4 and
probably you have to
be careful in this position with the
white pieces because
this skin easily stops the h pawn and
then at some point this this pawn
could start running right this eight
pawn so
no bishop d2 bishop d2 is actually not
working
so you got more candidate moves i mean
i'm gonna give you a hint
bishop e1 well bishop e1 i guess your
idea is to play bishop g3 but i just
play
king g3 and then if you cover
with bishop g3 then i just take and then
i take on c4 and black is winning
so basically we realize that the problem
is this guy on d6
the problem is this guy on d6 somebody
in the chat
is proposing the move h4 and
actually after h4 black can easily
survive again
with king g4 check again this guy
this damn guy on d6 ruining our day
i mean we were happy this day you know
went to a nice restaurant we had a date
the date went flying you know and
but then this vision from d6 is just
ruining everything because now after
this check you just captured the pawn on
h5 there is no more past pawn
on the h5 so though
bishop b4 okay somebody starts
realizing about the idea the idea
is just to i mean to keep this bishop
from d6 somehow right
i mean it's like you are in a date with
your with your
loved one with your girl with your guy
and uh
and then this bishop on d6 is just in
the middle of the table just eating
all the food and then stopped you from
kissing
so that's why you we're gonna kick him
you know get get the
get the hell out of here so bishop b4
that's the first idea
but this is actually losing again
because after bishop takes b4 now
h6 yes you know king g5 is not working
but this bishop again comes to your
table and
steals your foot so h7
and bishop g7 and you cover h8
so that's why bishop b4 is not working
somebody
saw the first move very well very good
like
igor and manny presici and
sukolinoa c5 that's a great move
deflection thing because now this bishop
is actually forced to take on c5
otherwise
then if you move the bishop c6 and c7 is
just win
so that's why bishop c5 and now h6
but you know this bishop i told you is
like the worst guy
ever you know it's a pain in the stomach
yeah so now this bishop is gonna try to
stop that pawn again it has two methods
first one in the f8 square second one in
the main diagonal by playing bishop d4
and f5 so i mean when you solve the
puzzle that means you have seen all
these
variations so it's not easy at all not
even for a grand master
so let's say black starts with the move
bishop f8 and now it's actually your
turn with the white pieces so give me a
move
candidates candidate moves it's y
turn right now
because if you if we play h7 then bishop
g7 this king is
only two moves away to capture the pawn
on h7
bishop d2 doesn't help because i just
play king f5 king g6 and then i just
take that one on eight six and probably
you're losing
so yes kevin you saw the move pretty
amazing
bishop b4 again deflection all the time
because if the bishop takes on b4
h7 wins if the bishop takes on h6 this
is the key
then there is a check on d2 and then we
grab the bishop on h6
and white wins the the game all right so
we stopped this bishop f8 idea now let's
just try to see what happens if black
plays
bishop d4 because black's idea is quite
simple you want to push facundo so you
cover
the h8 square right so again
we have to find a proper solution what
do we play here with the what with the
white pieces
probably some of you is gonna say
something like bishop b6
but then of course black is not forced
to take on b6
because if you take on b6 a7 swings but
black instead just
well just put the bishop for example on
b2
and then h7 you continue with f5 still
right
bishop c3 not working shane because i
just take the bishop and then
you know you got the same idea but now
with the b is up so
now you don't have even the date so
that's right the move
c3 and then if the black bishop
goes to e5 now what's the winning move
i mean again black is threatening to go
king g5
followed by king h6 that's right
bishop c7 fantastic move
fantastic move now the bishop cannot
stay in the long diagonal because there
is a pin
on this diagonal and if black takes down
c7 this is actually very similar to the
initial position but with uh with our
pawn on h6 that's why we play h7
it's true that black can now move the
queen the king sorry with a check
but the pawn is too far away we just
make this
move we feel like a sir with our monocle
and our suit and we just win the game
there's no way to stop h8 right
okay guys so fourth pause a fourth
puzzle solve let's go to the fifth one
let's go to the fifth one
one second
one second guys my mom is saying
something
and all right guys
so i got you here sorry for this
so let's think about this puzzle you
drive the white pieces
nice puzzle right nice geometry in all
of them
so all right so it's
white's turn um basically here i mean
you're gonna promote the d phone
otherwise
you can even lose this game so
let's think about defensive resources
for black i'll be the one
trying to defend this position with the
black pieces
so i guess the first move is very clear
to all of us right because if you play
something let's say like bishop c6
something like that
then i'll just put the knight on c5
nobody can kick this knight from c5
and whenever you go d7 then
i just take that pawn right and then we
reach some opposite color bishop end
game where actually it's
impossible to lose so that's right the
first move
is d7 it looks completely winning looks
completely winning
because i mean how we're gonna stop d8
in this position
right
how are we gonna stop d8 in this
position
well you guys tell me can you tell me
the best
defensive resource for black in this
position and the only one
that's right your g4
g4 and you know somebody can think i
mean what is this pepe saying again
i'm just so tired of his face you know
just bring me another guy you know so
king takes e4 what's the idea now i'm
covering the g5 square
so f5 i just take the pawn
right so
how are we gonna protect
the d8 square that's right
jesse 96 very strong player
he saw the idea a leonardo 2
that's right so we have to bring this
skin to this square
because that way when a knight comes to
c5
then if you promote with d8 then 96
would be a fork
and actually you grab the queen so what
do you think you think this move this
position is a draw
you think white is winning or what do
you think
what's going on who's better here
it's a draw it's white went in
and these are all the things you have to
see
before you make the first move before
before you play d7
i mean if if you want to solve the the
puzzle correctly yeah it's
i mean this is not what we should do
we shouldn't move d7 and then try to try
to analyze
from that point because things are
easier yeah but at home you guys would
be
i mean ideally you should be
i mean trying to solve the whole puzzles
the whole puzzle from the beginning
right it's a draw leonardo is saying who
votes for
the draw of bots for the win causeway is
voting for the win for white
well i gotta tell you that why this win
let's see how so basically bishop g5 is
actually forced
now white should take a knight c5
so we reach this position and then after
d8 we just
play 96 and then there is a fork and
then we grab the queen
i mean if you you play something like uh
like
d8 knight is not enough to win because
for example what would be
the best uh defensive resource after
d8 knight would you take on b7
i think i had to yeah let's just promote
a knight
how do you defend this position with the
black pieces do you take on b7
because actually one could think that
this is a this is winning for white
yeah you have any ideas
for black yeah 96 fantastic cause me
because after 96 sorry knight takes e6
pawn takes e6
this bishop is a light square bishop and
h8 is black
so that's why this end game even without
this pawn is actually a dead draw it's a
theoretical draw so that's why 96
just you know makes a draw so d8 knight
is not
is not possible either so how do we
continue
what's the best sequence for white in
this position
is it that wrong
wrong bishop color you're right here
vda that's a french name right
me not so good bishop c8 well bishop c8
again
black has the same uh resource knight
takes e7 then we reach the same kind of
end game so
actually these knight takes d7 is a
threat no matter how you protect that
pawn
that's right guys h6 very strong move
because now the black king can't go to
the back
to the eighth file right the background
because then d8
comes with a check and then there is no
fork so basically
black is forced to go to h7 and it looks
like black again
is taken on d7
this this puzzle is very beautiful i i
really like it
i really like it because there are so
many subtleties so many traps
right that black that white can go and
can't fall for
and now well what's the only move
to have chances here for for white yeah
that's right
bishop e4 check but still it's not
it's not the end of the puzzle it's true
that if black goes to g8 or
h8 then d8 is just it's just winning for
white but again i just take
the knight on e4 and then you tell me
you go 15 seconds in the clock and then
you're gonna make a move
after this check you have like
one two three four five squares to go
so you go to f5 you go to f4
what's your square let's see how many
people win the game let's see how many
people draw the game
key kin f5 kin f5 so we got two bots for
king of four three four
king of five
so yeah so three three king of four
one for king h4 so actually f4 and f5 is
winning
guys you actually blundered
almost all of you because if you go to
f4 then the same trick guys
now this skin is still you know in a bad
square
because now knight c5 is again a draw
so white has to promote and then 96 fork
saying happens with the move key in f5
because now black can just play knight
d6
and then stop the pawn
by coming to b7
so not possible to go to f5 or f4
and of course g4 is not an option
because of
knight f6 same applies for a key in h5
again knight f6 and actually black is
winning be careful
in this positions black is winning so
the only move is h square and then there
is no possible fork
i mean you will you will need a super
knight or something that come forth
from e5 to d8 and h4 super not even
superman or batman can make this fork
right knight is a tricky trick trickster
that's right
kaushik so as you see this puzzle was
beautiful
and basically with forcing moves you can
solve it
but there were so many tricks right the
90s
bad guy okay let's move to the
puzzle number six from the plot of
brothers this is a very funny puzzle
because
you know if you uh turn stuck fish on
uh you won't see the solution
until you make some moves that was
pretty funny for me today you know
i thought i had found the solution i was
analyzing over the board and then
i was i was saying to myself okay pepe
come on you you're teaching and i like
you you should you should
um you should
corroborate with uh with stockfish and
this is what i did and stockfish was
saying that this is actually a draw
okay
it's like a night check shadow that's
right
i got nine percent of battery in my cell
phone you guys think
it will last in the end of the class i
think so let's see
my cell phone is not that good
yeah so i mean the first move is kind of
clear right i mean we have to create a
passport
on the key inside
clearing the way for the e pawn or the g
pawn
so the first move is actually h5 now i'm
gonna try to give you
some nightmares for example what happens
if i play
king takes e3 what do you play with the
white pieces
finish your opponent
h6 well i i know this can be a
temptation but i just take the pawn on
e5 and
i will cover the h8 square so basically
h6 could be even losing in this position
well i'm not so sure
but for sure black is fine with the move
bishop takes e5 so h6 is not an option
so what do we play here sometimes it's
just uh
sometimes it's just simple chess what
works
yeah so 86 not a good idea
knight c5 check well next c5 check
yeah that could be an option and there's
a more direct approach come on guys
let's try to make a queen
yeah let's try to make a queen
past pawns must be pushed that's right
mr kihi
knight c5 looks interesting but how
about just
you know trying to push our pawns for
example h
takes f takes an e6 well not e6
immediately because after e6 then black
plays bishop a3 and stops the pawn so
now
i gave you the hint what should we play
here in this position
come on guys white wins
so we're saying that a6
bishop a3 so knight c5 check
and now when the king moves let's say to
c4
e6 and there is no way to stop this e
pawn which is gonna promote in two moves
actually
so that's why king takes d3 is not
possible
now i'm gonna propose you this move
quintex e4
of course then we'll analyze the most
natural move the most natural reply g
takes h5 but first of all let's analyze
this
kindy for the king tries to go back to
stop those little monsters yeah
knight king king d4 sorry so
pawn takes then my idea is to take and
then
you go e6 i think i can stop this bomb
with bishop a3
so after king d4
we have to play sometimes we we want to
create
a passport on the e file sometimes we
want to create a passport
on the ge file
so with this hand in mind what should we
play
in this position again eight
six i think is not enough because after
takes
then the king moves and then the bishop
covers h8
somebody is saying bishop a3 this is a
tough move
to make yeah bishop a3 probably you are
referring to sheerop's
best moving history of chess but not in
this puzzle right
e6 a6 is very interesting pawn takes
now h takes the king has to move
for example with king e3 and now
white just plays knight c5 knight takes
c6
and g7 and white wins the game
so that's why after h5 black is forced
to take on h5
and now how should we proceed in this
position
g takes h5 now it's white's turn again
so tough decision what should we do
create a passport on the g
file create a passport on the e file
well somebody's saying g6
g6 is actually the move and
i guarantee you just trying to put stuck
fish in this position
he won't see the solution not in this
point
it's just incredible it's one of those
positions where the engine is actually
not working amazing guys
can you give me one second so i bring in
my shirt my charger you think about this
position so i just take
now what do you move for example i play
e6
and then i play bishop a3 just bringing
my
my my charger yeah
all right i'm back
other than abandon abandoned you guys
so let me see if i have some
spots to put my charger i think there's
one left
so here i am
okay guys so bishop e3
how can we proceed i mean this bishop
looks so fantastically placed in the
square just topping
e7 i mean this skin is going to take on
d3
black has like three past pawns one on
each file the other one on g file the
other one on the d
file so what can we play somebody's
saying knight b8
okay knight p8 is just too slow for
example i mean kintex d3
knight takes c6 d4 e7 i just take on e7
uh this is actually a draw because
i mean this can just uh
also using this pawn this is gonna be a
dead draw
it's an extremely beautiful idea
and then we forgot about something we
were just so
you know focused on those pawns on the g
file and on the e file that we forgot
about another password that we have we
got the a
pawn we got the a pawn can we use the a
pawn somehow
in this position
so what do we play here with white i
give you
a big hint right now
yeah that's right that's right
knight b4 you cannot go to c5 don't do
this because after a4 the king stops the
pawn
and then the bishop stops up and stops
sorry this one
but you can go knight b4
actually black is forced to take with
the bishop
because he black takes with the king
then e7 just wins
so bishop takes b4 and a4 and actually
this bishop has two jobs
at this moment
and he has to be in both jobs
at the same time you know so
white is actually winning in this
position but okay it's not the end
it's not the end so let's say king takes
d3
for example king d4 just a5 and the king
can't go to c5
again there's e7 coming
and if the king comes to e5 again a6 a7
coming bishop c5 just e7 or a7 both wins
so but there is one more line don't
don't run away i know
you guys say you know i finished this
parcel you know i'm gonna take some
popcorns and then
bring a beer no not yet quintex e3
a5 kidney two a6
d4 a7 d3
a8 and d2 and what do you play here
with the white pieces because this pawn
is very close
to promote i mean if you play something
like queen a6 jaskini one
and there are no more checks and
actually black is promoting
and probably even winning
so these are all the details where i
mean that you have to check
[Music]
i mean right after you you solve the
puzzles
because probably some of them i mean you
didn't realize about them so
the more you see of course the better
you know
queen a2 queen a2 is actually the only
move but now i'm gonna play
king e1 what do you play still not easy
because now i'm just playing d1
this puzzle is also very beautiful you
know i mean i'm so happy just solving
puzzles you know i need
a few things in my life you know just a
bishop pair you know
some nice puzzles you know and then my
friends and you know i don't need
anything else that's right causeway
you're very strong today
just king g2 another interesting idea
because actually we're gonna put
this queen on this diagonal right
because the bishop is just protecting it
there is no check on the e5
so queen b1 well just d1 and actually
black is winning well for example queen
takes v4 we just play
king f2 with a check and that's gonna be
checkmate so very very careful queen b1
just loses
the idea is to play king g2 because
there is mate
on f2 and in this position black has to
resign it can never promote
with d1
awesome awesome let's go to puzzle
number seven
puzzle number seven white to move we got
i mean we're upon down so
black is intending just to capture this
pawn and of course you are not
going to have more than a draw in this
position
so i think the first move is pretty
clear for everybody right in this
position
then we will see what happens but the
first move has to be clear if you want
to win this position
what's your first move guys i mean you
should realize like in
half a minute what has to be the the
first move otherwise it's just not
possible
yeah if white promotes knight in the
previous example it's not enough you
know just a knight and a bishop against
a queen
so it's not enough and you got you got a
passer on the e5 that pawn on e6
yeah the first move has to be bishop c3
otherwise
i mean black just trades those pawn
those pawns and then there's nothing to
do right so bishop c3
do you prefer taking your games to end
games generally are you play this is
your playing style
i love end games guys yeah i feel very
comfortable
playing in some end games i don't mind
playing that's why i play openings like
philidor you know
i don't mind uh playing end games from
move number four for example
in the philidor they can take on e5 and
then queen takes e8
i'm unhappy to play till till tomorrow
for six seven hours you know
i'm a i'm a good fighter i'm very bad in
in other phases of the games but i'm a
good fighter so i don't mind playing
for six seven hours trying to grind my
opponent
um okay so bishop c3 that's the first
move
and of course we want to create a passer
on
the a file right so that's why
if the black king's black king goes to
h7 then our move is
very clear again bishop d3 check and
then the key moves and a6
and then there is no way for black to
stop this this pawn coming to asm
so that's why the first move the best
move for black
sorry is king g8 so how do we continue
in this in this position guys
again if there is a move that wins
it should be clear for you what kind of
move has to be
it may lose but it's the only try in
this position to win
bishop c4 that's the only trial then why
is the pawns get traded
so i mean if you are solving puzzles and
then you know that black
white has to win i mean it's giving you
a huge hint because otherwise it's just
no move i mean
even if you play bishop b2 then black
takes on a5 2 bishops
versus b bishops one bishop is just a
dead draw so it has to be
bishop c4 so knight takes e4 and a6
but then wait wait a second come on pepe
this is just losing
for white because i just played b5 well
now of course we have to cover
the square b6 so how should we continue
here
yes you have any ideas we got a lot of
people today following the class
i'm happy about this it's always nice
to interact with so many people you know
bishop d4 oh jonathan
you fell in the trap you fell in the
trap because now
c5 it's a fantastic move
you go a7 i just go knight b6 you take
on c5
bishop b6 and black manages to stop the
pawn
so that's why the best move is bishop a5
sacrificing a second piece covering b6
and if knight takes a5 a7 just wins
if black goes c5 then bishop takes d5
there is
no way this knight reaches
the basic square so bishop a5
i knew some of you were gonna fall in
the trap
when i said you have to cover the b6
square
because from d4 is actually the most
natural place
very good guys so only one puzzle left
and then we're done with the class let's
go to
puzzle number
eight it's white turn
so again white is going in this
direction
black is going in this direction and of
course
black is just threatening our pawn on c6
where do these end games come from
arthur there are uh
compositions from the platof brothers
they were from
latvia they uh i think they were players
in the
uh the beginning of the 20th
century i think they were born in the
19th century so
1880 something to 1940 or something
that's the period of time where they
lived
so i mean we got two options here no
more right
so we have to decide whether we go c7
or b should be one
and c7 well
that's a nice idea because then you say
i mean you play c7 then you
use your bishop to deflect black's
bishop but after bishop b7 for example
bishop b1 i guess that's your idea
keen f6 and then you want to go bishop
e4
the problem is that in this position and
black can hold with bishop c8 i guess
and then this skin is going
this is a check actually let's say king
g2 and now kini 5 attacked the bishop
and then king d6 and then
i just managed to get the c7 punk with
the troll
so c7 is actually not working
the move is bishop b1 check now black
king
tries to get closer to
the twins on the c file the carlitos
twins
kin f6 and now the only move is actually
again
bishop e4 but now my question is
what happens if black goes kidney 5.
black's idea is rather simple when i go
king d6 grab this spawn
and bye bye so how can you win this
position with the black pieces
you got two tries you can move the pawn
you can
move the bishop basically this is all
you can do in this position
bishop b1 somebody's saying this is just
very bad because i just grabbed the pawn
c7
c7 who votes for c7 a lot of boats for
c7
c7 winning so far some other ideas in
this position
c7 bishop f5 bishop f5 is not working
c7 everybody's saying c7 well you guys
all fell in the trap
c7 it's a dead draw and now you're gonna
see the idea
i just take on e4 and after c8 i just
play bishop f5
i'm surprised like
in kinder chocolate you got some
surprise queen f5 king of five the king
stops the pawn
and that's the draw so c7 is not working
so what what do we do then
bishop d5 somebody's saying well after
bishop d5 i just play
kin d6 and after c7 surprise
b5 if you take on d5 you take on c7 you
go c8 bishop e6
surprise so no
bishop d5 not working do you want to try
some
some new square c5 somebody's saying see
if i just grab the bishop and then after
c7 bishop b7 and then
i hide the bishop on c8 not working
so i mean of course black strategy just
to take the bishop and then after c7 you
play bishop b7
c7 not working i just take an e4 c7
c5 sorry then c7 bishop b7 c6 bishop c8
and black holes so
any ideas we tried c7
we tried bishop d5 i mean
it's impossible to solve where you have
only
three more options let's say
three more decent options in this
position we got
bishop s3 we got bishop g2 and then we
got bishop h1
what's the best square for the bishop
let's see what you think this is so
beautiful yeah
this is more beautiful than a sunset
in ibiza the best island in spain
bishop g2 bishop g2 bad move ron
kmd6 c7 surprise
then this comes with a check bishop g2
not a good move then you have two
options bishop f3 or bishop h1
that's right arthur you got it
bishop h1 is just winning if you go to
f3 then you get
the same surprise because of this little
guy on h5
you thought this guy i mean was not even
part of the problem
it was there for a reason you know
that's why compositions are so nice you
know
there's always a reason behind every
piece so now you go
king d6 c7 surprise because after c8
then bishop g4 now the pawn is
supporting the pressure
so the best move is bishop h1
and now after king d6 c7 works there's
no surprise
the bishop takes on h1 and then it kind
of
checked from let's say h i j j
1 there is no j1 right in chess it would
need
h1 to to capture the queen on c8
very nice right so now king c7 bishop a8
just wins again
we have another passer after bishop h1
just skin c7
sorry c8 and there's no
check right here right
okay guys so i think with this puzzle we
finish
the lecture and at least
i had a lot of fun i hope you guys felt
the same
and hope you guys learned something
different i think these puzzles
as i told you so many times increase
your creativity for sure
and it will help to you to grow your
game okay guys so
this uh this is it for today i think
i'll come back
um on thursday actually with two new
lectures
normally grandmaster choice and then the
week uh
games from from from the week so recent
games probably will analyze some games
from the us championship
i'm always open to suggestions if you
guys leave some comments
in in the youtube video i read all of
them so
feel free to to drop your suggestion
i'll be happy to
to take that in account for the next
lectures so it's been a pleasure
just uh big hacks from spain and take
care
and stay healthy yeah bye guys see you